[MUSIC PLAYING]
JASON COHEN: So I've
been building companies
for 20 years in Austin,
Texas, and currently,
started a company
called WP Engine
about 9 and 1/2 years ago.
And we're big users of the
Cloud, as you're about to see.
And in particular, we've just
transformed our corporate data
and our processes around
there using technology
from Google and some
code of our own,
which I'm going to
show you both of.
So hopefully this
is useful to you.
So here's where you go, oh,
wow, your stats are so big.
You guys are amazing
and successful.
I think my favorite one here
is, 5% of every human who
is online today, which is
about 3.5 billion people,
come to one of our
properties every day.
And so what we do is, we are
the most used and most popular
platform for running WordPress
digital experiences--
so WordPress being the
open source project
that powers one third of
every domain on earth today.
And we power a lot of the larger
sites that use WordPress there.
So that's all cool.
And we have more than a
third of a million sites
running on Google Cloud.
And also, I'm going to
show you this NASCAR slide
of a lot of customers.
And the reason is
actually to impress you
because everyone's got logos.
But rather, in the
context of corporate data,
it's very easy, as
engineers, to think,
I know, I'll just grab all
the data from all the places
and stick it somewhere, and
then we'll make reports.
Duh, it's the obvious thing.
And there are
various reasons why
that's not as simple as
what the real problem is.
And this is one reason.
Because a lot of these folks
have requirements on us
about what we do
with their data.
And as you probably
know, starting in Europe,
but now here as
well, companies are
getting more and more strict
about what their vendors are
able to do, what kinds
of security practices
you have to have around
that, whether you
need to do SOC 2 and that
sort of stuff, or what.
And so when we think about
collecting our corporate data,
which, of course, includes
our customers' data
and data about
customers, we have
to think about what restrictions
are they putting on us?
What audits do they give us?
Because we have to pass
those while still doing what
we want to do with data.
That actually makes
it kind of hard.
Again, I'm going to show you
how we work through that.
So we had a challenge for
ourselves recently, which is--
we have about 100,000
customers, which is nice--
and as we scale and grow
the number of customers,
everything else scales--
servers and difficulties,
processes and corporate data.
So we have this
company-wide mantra
of, hey, how are we going
to support half a million
customers, so about
5x where we are today?
And I think this is actually
an interesting pattern
to use, in general,
when thinking
about how to plan ahead.
So a lot of folks
just say, well,
when something
breaks, we fix it.
That's, of course,
not planning ahead.
That's being always behind,
by definition, right?
And the other way is to say--
and as engineers, we like this.
Well, what if it's 10
or 100 times bigger?
What would we need to build?
And that's fun because it's fun
to think about how to architect
something that large.
It's also not necessary.
You're not going to be 100
times bigger anytime soon.
Most things aren't
going to be, anyway.
And so you end up
over-architecting.
And so this kind of rule
of thumb of, maybe 5x,
is, to me, a nice rule of
planning in general for stuff,
whether data or otherwise.
It's enough in the future
that you're looking ahead,
but not going crazy and
over-architecting stuff.
So that was sort of our
guiding principle there.
And so what we wanted
to do is say, all right,
we've got corporate data.
What does that mean?
It means financial data right
off of our general ledger
or the invoices that we
charge customers every month.
Again, we process about
70,000 invoices a month
because most customers
are month to month.
And then there's data
about our user portal.
There's data on
the actual servers.
We run almost 10,000
servers around the world.
And so what's going on there?
And what's happening inside
of our customers' sites?
So we process about 10
billion web requests a day.
So just logging all
that, and sticking
it somewhere, which, by the way,
is BigQuery, is already a feat.
And there's all kinds
of interesting stuff
in there about security--
patterns you could look
at for security, patterns
you could look at
for performance,
like what could be cacheable or
blocked or something like this.
So all kinds of interesting
stuff going on there--
and that's true big data.
Even at Google, 10
billion thingies a day
is a lot, no matter who you are.
So most of our data, of
course, is not big data.
Most of anybody's data is not
big data, but it is just data,
and some of it's big.
So how do we go around
all these systems--
the weblogs, the financial
systems, Salesforce,
the support systems, tickets
and chats, our servers?
How do we take all this
data and put it somewhere
that is secure,
that we can clean,
that we can audit,
that we can connect,
that we can give to
other analysts and people
in the company for
their various reasons
why they care about data?
How can we do that?
That was our question.
And so of course, I'm
going to describe how
we did this this whole time.
We called it "Grand Central
Data Station" because we're
engineers, and we're
terrible at naming things,
and so that's what we called it.
Anyway, so this is what we did.
And I'm going to show you how
we wrote some code around this,
and what it got us, and also how
we leveraged tools from Google
to do some of the hard
work for us as well.
So the first thing is, when you
think about a big data project,
is to define your
systems of record,
which sounds simple enough.
It's just, where all
the places there's data?
But it's a little
bit more than that.
It's where is their
data, and what data
does that system actually own?
So for example, Salesforce,
for us, owns the sales data.
It's what the sales folks do.
And we have customer
data in there.
But that's not the source
of truth for customers.
That is not the
system that determines
what is a customer or not.
It determines what
the salesperson
did, which isn't
necessarily the same thing.
So we even have systems
that try to automate,
whenever there's a new customer,
putting it in Salesforce.
We determined later that there
were 5,000 incorrect records
there.
Because there's a difference
between owning the data
and having a copy of it or
having some kind of notion
about it, right?
So it's important.
What are those things?
So for us, it's these
sorts of things,
and what does it actually
own, and defining that
and bringing it in.
Because, ultimately, when you
put all the data together,
of course, it's the
systems of records' data
that's the interesting part.
And you might want
to push some of that
back out, like we do
with customer data
back to Salesforce, so that the
people who are using the tool
have access to it.
But it's important
to know what's what.
And it's not obvious
right away what that is.
So that's the first thing,
those systems of record.
And then the second
thing is building
a place where it can
all come together,
so hence, the central station.
And again, there's all
these challenges with it.
The places you're
pulling from each
have its own way
of authenticating
and how the credentials work.
So there has to be a way to
securely store that and still
pull it automatically,
which I'll describe.
Of course, there are
different data formats.
There's databases like
MySQL and Postgres,
in our case, and
all these systems,
like Salesforce,
Zendesk, et cetera,
where it might be behind an API.
So there are all these different
ways which it comes from.
And by the way, the reason
to solve all this now
is because this is why people
can't connect data today.
Because it's too hard
to grab something out
of Salesforce and something
out of something else
and put it together
for any normal person.
So this is hard, but
it's kind of the point.
Centralization is
important too because there
are a lot of insights you can't
get unless you connect data
from disparate sources.
So you might want to say,
hey, we have customers
where their traffic is growing.
And they're using more
and more of our services.
And they are either
not contacting support,
or they have happy
support calls.
In other words,
they're rating it high.
Here's a happy growing customer.
That might be something a
salesperson would want to know,
right.
But that involves connecting
stuff from support
and from the farm--
which is what we
call our servers--
and Salesforce.
What if we're already
talking to them?
Then they don't need to be
on a new contact report.
So that's a very basic example.
But it shows spanning a
whole bunch of systems.
So centralization is important.
And of course, the problem,
though, with centralization,
is security.
If I have everything in my
company in a table in BigQuery,
whoever has access to that
has access to too much stuff,
right?
It certainly violates
whatever kind of policies
you might have.
So it's a problem.
So we centralize the data.
When it's centralized,
and you have algorithms
like cleaning stuff
up, it's really nice
that everything's centralized
because you can run them
on everything.
For example, we
have country fields.
And people use, sometimes it's
a two-digit code or three-digit
code or fill-in-the-blank
like Salesforce.
And we have people in sales--
I'm picking on sales a lot,
but you know, whatever.
Our Salesforce has, like, 300
columns in the accounts table,
so there's a lot to make fun of.
Anyway, so for example,
in the country field,
they would say,
like, London, which
clearly was some
American who's confused
about how countries work.
And so there's all this stuff.
And so having algorithms
that clean it,
it's nice to make those,
test those, and apply those
once, and not in all the
different systems, of course,
analyzing, and connecting
the data, and so forth.
And again, I'm going to show you
how we did that with our code
and with BigQuery and
solved those problems.
So we had a whole bunch of
goals, which we succeeded at.
And some of them
are not obvious-- so
automatically refreshing
the data, that's obvious.
But let me skip down to an
audit trail where you can find,
in an end user report, exactly
the whole trail of formulas
of where it came
from, all the way back
to the original
systems of record
where the data really lives.
That's something the
data analysts never get.
Or they get documentation,
and it, of course,
gets out of date right away.
So that was going to be a really
powerful thing if we could
do it, which I'll show you.
Or what's Personally
Identifiable Information,
or PII?
There are a lot of privacy laws
around things that are PII.
But if you're an end user with
a report, how do you know column
three and seven are PII, and
you have to be extra careful,
or they're not?
Again, not something
you normally get--
so there's some neat stuff
I'm going to show you
that we are able to achieve.
So we picked
BigQuery, of course,
because I'm standing here.
So obviously, we
use Google stuff.
There's a couple of reasons.
One is, as a company
that has 10,000 servers,
we know for sure we do
not want more servers.
We know that stinks, and
we don't want servers.
And a lot of these databases,
even when they're managed,
and, in fact, even other
databases at Google,
even though they're
managed, there
are [? knobs ?]
and things still.
It's like, well, do you want
to start with three databases
all over, because
high availability.
and here's how you
do the failover.
And here's how you might scale.
And then you've got
to redo the disc.
And you're just, like, that's
not what I want to do ever.
Nobody wants to do that.
Do it for me.
And one of the great
things about BigQuery
is it really is that.
It really is-- today I
have one row is in a table.
And tomorrow, I have 1
trillion rows in a table.
And I just pay a little
bit more for storage.
That's actually how it
works, which is really nice.
Again, we have these
huge amounts of weblogs.
So that alone is useful to
have something that scales.
Performance in BigQuery
is interesting.
We can run a query over
these logs and process
trillions of rows, summarize
all kinds of stuff,
and get an interesting
answer in seven seconds.
Also, you can ask it what
time it is in a query,
and it will also
take seven seconds.
So everything in BigQuery
takes a little bit of time,
but you can ask it
as much as you want.
That's not completely true.
If you stack up queries, or
you really have a lot of data,
it could start slowing down.
I'll show you something
that we did about that.
But in general, the performance
for large amounts of data
is really nice.
One area that's not nice
is, if you have a report,
and you're filtering
stuff, and changing stuff,
and each one of those
is a different query.
Because in those
seven seconds- makes
the iteration time really slow.
So that's where using some kind
of BI tool in front of BigQuery
is useful.
And so in our case,
we use Looker.
But of course, there's
a lot of good ones.
That's just what we
happened to pick.
And what we found is that kills
that, sort of-- you might say,
the equivalent of the
last-mile problem of,
I'm an end user
looking at a report,
and I want to quickly
look at stuff.
If you have a BI tool there,
it can do that last-mile set
of filtering and stuff.
And that can be super fast and
convenient for that person.
And you don't incur the
problems of BigQuery's slowness.
So security is another one.
So I mentioned
this thing where--
I mentioned the security
problem of, OK, I
put all my data in one place.
And data people call
that a data lake, right?
I don't know if that's
a good analogy, a lake.
It's kind of a good
analogy in that it's
just a whole bunch of
stuff all mixed up,
and you can't find it anymore.
And it's all there, I
guess, but who knows?
So I guess it's an OK analogy.
But anyway, when you put
all the data together,
the good news is, you
can clean it and connect
it and all that stuff.
And the bad news
is, you kind of want
no one to have access to it.
So it's kind of a problem.
So here's what you
can do in BigQuery,
and this is what
we've been doing.
So you put all the
data somewhere.
Obviously, this is
all locked down,
and almost no one can get to it.
Maybe service accounts
can and so forth.
Then the marketing
department needs
some stuff, so what do we do?
So we create what is,
in BigQuery, called
a dataset, which is
really just like a folder.
And you can put stuff in the
folder, like views and tables.
So in particular, we
put views in there.
So the way it works is, we
figure, oh, marketing-- there's
some funnel report or
something that they need.
So we can pick all this data
out and make some awesome view
that contains all the data one
would need for this report.
So we take that view, and we
put it in a marketing dataset.
Then we give
marketing, the group,
access to that
marketing dataset.
And now, although marketing
does not have access
to the underlying tables,
cannot go in there,
they are allowed to
see what's in the view.
So that means really easily--
like point-and-click easy--
we can provide datasets
in the form of views
to whomever, have complete
access control there,
and any policies we want
about what we show to whom
and how we check that off,
or not having much policies,
depending on the situation.
It's very easy to
be flexible there.
And so we can have
the data together,
create those unique
reports, but then
give people only the
resulting report, which
they can then take directly.
They can take it to Data Studio.
They can take it to
Looker, et cetera,
however it is that they
want to consume it.
So the security
model in BigQuery
that allows us to do that
and use the normal Google
users to do that was
extremely convenient
for us to just be able to make
these things easily and not
worry too much about security.
So that was really helpful.
So this is roughly
what we built. So we
built this system in Python.
And the part that's
filled in a little bit
is the part that's
our Python code.
And, again, I'm
going to show you
a little bit about what we did.
And so the main thing here--
because much of this
won't be surprising.
It's just boxes and arrows
with words in the middle
that you've seen before,
mostly, so it's not a big deal.
But here's the interesting part.
You see, in the very, very
front there, in the data engine,
it says specifications and JSON.
I'm going to describe this
in detail and show you.
This is kind of the key
that makes this whole thing
work well.
And If we didn't do
this, and we just
tried to use BigQuery
alone or some BI tool,
we wouldn't be able to
achieve all those bullet
points on the other page.
So I'm going to explain
how he did that.
But roughly, we have JSON
specifications that say,
here's how to pull data
from systems of record
and also JSON
specifications that say,
here's how to transform that
data into more usable views.
I'm going to show you that.
Now, these are our data
sources, CMDB, BAPI.
These are our own names.
There are own internal tools.
So we're reaching into things
like MySQL and Postgres
to grab stuff out of there and
pulling that into BigQuery.
And also we used segment.io
for some of these SaaS tools
that have APIs, like Salesforce
and Zendesk and Stripe.
And I know today, it
was just announced,
there are even more tools
now to automate that stuff.
So, hooray!
Maybe this is even easier.
But anyway, when we
were doing this just,
maybe four months ago, Segment
was able to handle that,
and we had to handle
our own stuff.
Now, I think it's even
easier because Google
wants you to put a lot of
data in BigQuery, of course.
Because then you're
paying them more money
and using their stuff.
Of course, they
want you to do that.
Of course, it's going to
get more easy to pull stuff
into BigQuery.
But that's good.
So anyway, once it's
in there, then the data
gets transformed--
I'm going to show you that--
into those reports,
like I mentioned,
and various documentation,
and so forth.
OK.
So here's an example
of fraction of JSON.
I hope you can read that.
If you can't, then
it's green text
that looks like JSON that
is about systems of record.
So the way it works is, we
say, all right, well, here's
a table somewhere.
Here's a key to a
credentials file,
which, of course, is
elsewhere and not checked in,
as you would expect, for
how to get to this system.
And then we define all the
columns with lots of metadata.
What's the data type?
Is it null or not?
Is this a primary key for the
table, a human description,
like in just regular prose, of
what this is, and also possibly
some metadata like, what is
the quality of this data?
Is this PII, some
of those things
that I mentioned earlier?
We can tag them in here
just by saying it's true
or giving it a number.
So by doing this,
already what we
can do is automate the
sucking of the data out
of the systems of record and
stuffing them into BigQuery.
So what we do is, we
say, OK, every time we
retrieve the data,
we want to get
the data we haven't seen yet.
So we do that by looking
at the primary keys
and saying, well, whatever we've
gotten up to whatever date,
anything that's newer
than that, we'll take.
As well as if the data's
equal, then whatever
is newer than the last primary
key on that date that we got.
So in other words, tie
goes to the primary key.
So by doing that,
we can incrementally
update as often as we want.
At the moment, it's every hour.
But it's easy to do that.
The other thing we can
do is validate the data.
So if we say, in
here, it can be null.
Fine.
But if we say in here,
the data cannot be null,
but we see one come
through, we can flag it.
We can decide not to do it.
We can stall.
We can let it in any
way and emit a warning.
Whatever is the way that you
want to handle that is fine.
But we're able to check and
validate the data on the way
in from the system of
record, which might be dirty.
There are more things that this
can do, which you'll see next.
So this is an example of
JSON, which looks just
like the other JSON,
if you can't see it,
which is a transformation.
And here, the JSON has
got structures which
look a lot like a SQL query.
So there's a SOURCES in
there, which is like a JOIN.
It says, here are the different
tables I want to pick from,
maybe some join
keys, some columns
I may want to inherit
from that table.
And also, here are some
columns I want to compute.
In this one, there's
one called is_fraud.
And there's an
expression in there,
which, if you look
at it, looks sort
of like Lisp or something--
function, argument, argument,
argument, maybe the arguments
have functions too,
like Lisp, right?
In other words,
like a parsed tree--
that's what it looks like.
So here, we're checking whether
some possibly null field
in a fraud table is either the
word fraud or the word band.
And if so, then that means it's
a Boolean, IsFraud and blah,
blah, blah-- this
kind of basic stuff
that you do when you clean
data or calculate stuff.
There are also filters, which
is sort of like a WHERE clause
in SQL, right-- only the rows
which match this and so forth.
And all these expressions
are sitting there in JSON.
And so, of course, you might
think, well, this is dumb.
Just write SQL.
Like, this is a
lot more verbose.
What are you doing?
And so what we're
doing is actually
getting a whole lot of neat
benefits by doing this.
So one of the things we can
do with this Python that
reads in the JSON, of course,
one of things it can do
is make the SQL that makes
this view in BigQuery
and stick it in BigQuery,
which, of course, we do.
So duh.
Other things it can do
is check our own errors.
Are the data types right?
Are we handling nulls correctly?
So all these kinds of
things that can be wrong,
this code can detect it, first
off, so that we don't just
accidentally find it later.
Sometimes databases
will complain.
Sometimes they won't and
just sort of proceed.
And that's not good.
We want to catch--
we want to be extra
pedantic here.
We want this to be like
extra linted, extra careful
here because data
is so important.
It is important
to get everything
exactly right in this use case.
So we don't want to
be sloppy at all.
Or things that are convenient--
so for example, maybe
I'm concatenating
a string together.
And in SQL, all those things
have to be strings already.
But we can say, oh, look,
you're concatenating strings.
Oh, look, that one's a number.
Eh, it's cool.
We'll just throw the
CAST operator in there
for you when we make the SQL.
You don't need to do that.
That's just a bother.
So there are various
things in SQL
which can be annoying,
which we can actually
just clean up and hide.
I'll give you an example.
There is a really
fancy way in BigQuery
where you can refer to things
like the previous row, which
is kind of weird, right?
You're emitting
things, and you can
ask about the previous--
or even the next one that
hasn't been emitted yet.
That's pretty cool.
Because there are all kinds
of really neat calculations--
running sums, or numbering
things a certain way--
all kinds of neat things you
can do if you can reach forward
and backward a little
bit and do stuff.
You can do that in BigQuery, but
the expressions are confusing.
They can be kind of
long just to do that.
And especially someone
who understands enough
SQL to want to do that and
write this kind of thing,
but doesn't understand enough
to get into the windowing
systems and analytic
functions in BigQuery,
which are confusing--
so we can provide a function
called, like, NEXT or PREVIOUS.
And you just say I want
the next field of this.
And it turns into this
BigQuery expression.
And thanks, BigQuery, for
being able to do that.
That's cool.
But thanks to this,
the operator does not
have to know how to
do that correctly.
We can generate that confusing
thing for the operator.
So that's nice, because we can
do relatively complex things
that don't look so complex
when you're writing it.
So even just making the SQL,
there are advantages here.
The next thing,
though, is what else
can we do now that we have
all this metadata about it?
So one of the things
that kind of--
classically annoying about
data is documentation.
You've got to have good docs
because the end users are not
programmers, generally.
They could be analysts
or even someone
just looking at a report
who's not even an analyst.
And you want to document stuff
like how this came to be,
or what these fields mean,
or allow someone to audit it,
especially in finance.
You have audits.
And so you need you need
that traceability of where
this data comes from, especially
if you're going to use it
in a financial context,
and your company
gets to a certain scale.
You must be able
to have an audit
or trace of where
that came from.
So you have documentation.
We know how that goes-- code and
documentation being separate.
That means they never
match, and then you
don't know what's going on.
Of course, that's how
it works, but not here.
Because our documentation
is completely
generated only
from all that JSON.
And so the documentation and
the queries are never different.
So here's an
example of something
that our documentation creates.
So this is a tree of how
a certain table, called
the ledger, which is used
by finance, gets created.
And so you can see
here, in purple
are the systems
of record tables,
and in yellow are
these transformations,
and then, finally, the table.
Now, of course, there's
individual documentation
for every one of these steps.
But right away, you can
see, as an end user,
like, oh, this is complicated.
And you get a sense of
what goes into what.
And so if you are
auditing, if you
are trying to figure it out,
you have a map, at least,
of this very complicated thing.
You at least have a
map of what's going on,
which is already helpful.
This, by the way,
is created using
something called Graphviz.
And if you haven't
seen it, it's one
of these tools that
are, like, 20 years old,
but most people still
don't know about it.
It's really cool.
You can just say things like,
this node goes into that one,
and this one goes into that one,
and it lays it out like this.
And then you can say,
oh, and also this one
has a yellow background.
So actually, this is real easy.
You can do it on
the command line.
This is with a Python
client wrapper.
So this whole thing
just takes something
like 10 lines of code total.
Because we just look
through the JSON.
And how do we tell
the dependencies?
Because we have the joins.
And since we have the joins,
we can just walk them,
and that's the dependencies.
It's actually pretty easy.
And then we feed it
into this Graphviz
and just give it arrows.
And so this is almost no
code to crap out this ping.
And so we do this on
every single table.
Automatically, we
have this nice map.
Another example-- so we have
hyperlinked HTML documentation
on every single column
and every single table
in the whole system,
which would really
suck to have to do by hand.
I don't know many tech
writers you'd need
and what you'd have
to bribe them for it
to just sit through
it. but anyway--
so this is just two examples
of what this looks like.
So if you look
here on the left--
I know it's going to be a
little bit hard to read.
What we're doing is saying quite
a few things about the data.
So I'm going to walk
you through some of it.
So if you look on the
left, the left column
where it says
agency_natural_sales_team,
what we're doing here is
saying, hey, for a given agency
that we work with, there's
some sales team where,
because of their
geographic location,
they're the natural sales team
to have this agency, which
may not be the same
thing as the sales team
that actually has the agency.
This is the detailed data stuff
that's actually really helpful.
Without a complex system, it's
hard to get this kind of data.
So it says that it's
not null over there
in the corner, which is nice
if you're making reports.
And it says data quality is 70%.
Where did that come from?
So again, we can
annotate fields and say
what the data
quality is all back
in the system of record area.
So then in the
transformation JSON,
you can imagine
saying, all right,
if we know that you picked
this expression, and this one,
and this one, and this one,
and added them, and one of them
has a lower data
quality, then the result
has a lower data quality.
And of course, you could
argue about, if two of them
have low, do they multiply,
or just the lowest?
You could argue about how data
quality should be measured
and how that should
progress, whatever?
Point is, you could pick
and decide how that works.
And so, in the end result, we
can see it's not that good.
And the reason it's not
that good is this data
comes from that thing I
told you about earlier where
people put in strange data.
And so this is
OK, but not great.
Also, we imported data from
a data source that we bought.
And we know that data
source is about 70% right.
We were able to write all that
in in the original data sources
so that, later, when
someone's computing
this thing, this fairly
complicated thing, that
just shows up.
And again, a human doesn't
have to maintain that.
It just shows up, and
it's in the documentation.
So the next thing it does is--
again, there are
people who write SQL,
and that's probably the
people in this room.
And then, for everybody
that writes SQL,
there are 10 or maybe
even 50 other people
at the company who need to
consume it and don't know SQL.
So the other thing we
do is we write out,
in kind of English-ish,
what is the formula?
Which, if you think about it,
if you have the expression,
it's not that hard just
to format that thing
as HTML instead of
formatting it as SQL.
So in this case, if
this condition holds,
then we use this value.
This is a SWITCH
statement, right?
OK, so the thing on the
left-- if the first value
matches any of these,
so that's an IN, right?
Like, this isn't rocket science
about how this is working.
It's straightforward.
But by doing that, and you
can see by using bullets,
we can indent.
So if it gets complicated,
that can just match--
it can match the indentation
you would see in code.
It matches that with
bullets, so you see
that all kind of works out OK.
And in fact, this
is a complex formula
that is actually kind of
hard to read, even in code.
And this is kind of nice.
But this is something
that an analyst
can read without knowing SQL.
OK.
If one of these--
I see all this
Australia stuff there,
then it's Australia,
New Zealand.
Gotcha.
OK.
If they're in the US,
but also if they're
in one of these states in the
US, or later on, it says--
or maybe they're in
Canada, et cetera,
then they're in the
North America East Group.
But if I'm in sales,
and I'm going,
wait a minute,
how did you decide
who's in North America East?
It's super easy to
just go see that.
And if it's wrong, by the
way, easy to see and go
tell the developer,
oh, this city
is supposed to be
in the other thing,
and very easy for
the developer to fix.
But without that, good
luck ever finding that.
You're going to maybe find it.
It's very hard.
But just by making
it easier to read,
and because we have the
stuff in the JSON format,
it's super easy to make those.
Otherwise, that'd be hard.
So the stuff on the right
is more like for auditing.
So this is just different
tabs that we have in the HTML.
And this one we call origins.
And the idea is, all right,
I've got an expression.
And what are all the systems
of records and all the fields
in those systems of
record that were touched
in the making of
this final result,
recursively, like
everywhere, what got touched?
So it's just a big ol' list,
sorted by where it came from,
but it's a big ol' list.
That may not seem that useful
as an engineer, because it's
useful to not flatten
things out for an engineer.
It's good to chunk things.
But if you're an
auditor, this is great.
Are you sure PII wasn't used
in the making of this field?
Well, that's all the data that
was used in making the field.
So if one of these needs to
be PII, we can go mark it.
And then this will
say PII, no problem.
But, on the other hand,
if this is all clean,
an auditor can go, yeah, right.
This is all clean.
We're good.
Again, as an auditor,
this is huge.
And if you're in finance,
if the auditor's happy,
then you're happy.
That's it.
And even as a developer, the
auditor comes to you and says,
you need to document
this, and explain that.
That's annoying.
To be able to hand
this over and say,
let me know if you
have any questions,
is awesome, as an
engineer, that you
don't have to do that yourself.
So it may not seem
amazing, but it is
for these use cases for data.
So then, not everyone
wants to consume SQL.
Actually, a lot of
data analysts nowadays
do want to consume SQL
directly, and that's great.
And so for those
that don't, we wanted
to pick a standardized
tool for the company,
for people to build
reports and such.
And we picked Looker.
There's obviously a lot of good
ones to pick from nowadays.
And everybody's
going to integrate
with BigQuery, which is nice.
It's another reason to pick
one of the winners in the data
warehousing world to maximize
your options for integrations.
So we picked Looker.
There are a couple of
reasons, just if you're
curious why we didn't pick--
and it's not like we--
I don't really care
which one you pick.
I'm not shilling for Looker.
But in case this is useful
to you, Looker caches data.
And that means it's both faster
for the end user and cheaper.
Because BigQuery,
of course, charges
for storage, which generally
isn't that much, unless you
have all the records that
we have, and for query time.
And so if you cache,
then that means
you're even less worried about
what Google's charging you.
Another thing is, Looker
makes it very easy
to build reports in which you
can filter and double-click.
And there's
something people love
about being able to drill
down by double-clicking.
They love to drill down.
And Looker-- I don't know.
It makes it easy.
People love that stuff.
The other thing is, whatever
you're looking at in Looker,
with all the filters and the
drilldowns and the things--
is all in the getURL.
So you can just bookmark
or throw that URL
at somebody or whatever.
And they can leap right
into that particular thing.
And that's not true of
some of these other tools.
That's just so
handy, in practice,
to be able to do that.
Or if you're building
dashboards-- so I'm an analyst.
And I have three dashboards
I build for my function.
I mean, for me to
be able to just say,
oh, I'll have three tabs, and
each one is just this URL.
And updating what's in it
is just updating the URL.
How easy is this?
It's super easy.
Or people on their laptops
can just bookmark a URL.
It becomes really easy to do.
Also, all the things that
are in there are embeddable.
So, for example, there's
a lot of this kind
of data we wanted to
put into Salesforce,
into the UI of Salesforce.
Because if you're in the sales
team, you live in Salesforce.
You don't want to live in
Salesforce and some reporting
tool and be jumping around.
That's not good.
So with Looker, we're able to
take these reports, or charts,
or whatever kinds of things.
And just a little
piece, like one chart
with this filter on it of
the past week, or whenever--
and you can embed that
right into the dashboard
in Salesforce with
no code in Salesforce
and no special crap,
no special add-ons.
You can just embed it,
again, in part, because
of this deep linking
that goes right in.
So that means we're able
to build, the sales team--
I should say, the
sales ops team is
able to build
dashboards in Salesforce
for the reps and the managers.
But they never have to
leave Salesforce to get
this data, which is awesome.
Again, that's Looker.
But they still have
the double-click.
So if they go, well,
what about this bullet?
Now, they're in Looker,
and they can go play.
So it's just, again, a
really nice thing for people.
And again, as engineers,
sometimes you think of this,
like, who cares?
So it's embedded in this
dashboard instead of that one.
Or so what, you can click on it?
It doesn't sound
like a big deal,
but in practice, especially for
non-technical people, the idea
that it's just there,
and I can click and get
more is actually a really
big usability factor.
And that's what this part of
the system should be about
is usability for the folks
that need to use the data.
So that's what we picked.
So a couple of things--
it was harder to connect to
all the systems of record
than we thought, even
with things like Segment.
We actually had to file and get
some bugs fixed from Segment
just to get our
Salesforce data to work.
So it wasn't easy.
We also ran into some
trickiness with secrets.
So for example, we
used Apache Airflow
to create a workflow around
how to pull all this data.
So in other words, pull
it from all these systems,
and then make these
transformations, and then
these, and the whole series--
we used Apache Airflow-- it's a
workflow system-- for defining
those and doing it.
Once again, how did
we create those rules?
We got it from the JSON,
and we spit it out,
and it goes right into Airflow.
And Google has a
managed Airflow,
by the way, which we use.
And then it runs those
things on Kubernetes.
So then we were able to
use the Kubernetes Secrets
system to actually take
all those Secrets to all
those systems--
which, of course,
those are crown jewel secrets.
So that's really careful.
Our financial data, our customer
data-- this is a scary stuff.
But by being able to put it
into the vault in Kubernetes
and letting it
run in there, it's
a nice, safe way where no human
being ever gets their mitts
on those secrets.
And yet, we can automate
the pulling of all the data.
So that's really nice.
So it was hard to get
that to work, actually.
It was non-trivial
to figure out how
to get multiple things
into the vault, how
to make sure the Kubernetes
got the stuff out of the vault.
These things were not
easy for us to get up
and running at first.
But once they were
running, it's now
been running for
maybe 3 and 1/2 months
with not one problem, no
maintenance issue, no nothing
at all.
So that's really good.
So overall, it was really
good, even though it
was a challenge to get going.
It's still difficult,
to this day,
to understand what
data is right.
And I think, even though
we've built a lot of systems
for that, it's still hard.
So for example, we'll pull
data from our general ledger.
We'll pull data from Stripe
where we run the credit card
side of the business
and from the user
portal where we show invoices.
And there will be customers
where that stuff doesn't match.
And you say, OK.
But all this stuff is
supposed to be right.
And at that point,
Google can't help you.
And JSON can't help you.
And so just running through
all that has taken--
and we continue to work
on that stuff today--
it has taken a lot more
time than we expected.
When we've talked
to other folks,
even in the server business,
about billing and those kinds
of areas, we discovered that
Google has this problem.
Amazon has this problem.
Rackspace had this problem.
Actually, billing turns out to
be really hard, but who knew?
But actually, it's really hard.
So at least, though, we have a
system where it's easy for us
to understand what it is that
we are doing in the first place
and, therefore, maybe
iterate and diagnose.
The other thing we
did is we made tests.
Obviously, unit tests,
integration tests-- everybody
knows that.
So of course, we did that.
The other thing that we did is
these spot-check smoke tests.
So what we'd do is we'd say,
we'd discover some customer
with weird data,
and so, OK, we would
create a CSV file of the
result of some report
against that customer
that was actually right.
And that became a test, right?
So every time we update
all the corporate data,
we'll run this particular
report and check it
against the test CSV to make
sure that we didn't break that.
So it's like an integration
test in that it's
an end-to-end test, but it's
on the actual production data.
So it's like a third
level of tests.
So of course, in those,
we have to be careful just
to read and validate and
never change anything,
unlike an integration
test where you're
allowed to change the state,
because you can reset it.
So by having just the system--
and we've probably all built
these kinds of things where you
can drop a CSV file somewhere
and drop a query somewhere
and add a test easily--
because of that, we've been able
to add about 100 tests, which
doesn't sound like a lot.
But we have maybe 500
or 600 unit tests.
But we were able to
add an end-to-end test.
So now, even when
we find something
really strange in a boundary,
and we make a little change
to the JSON, we're very
confident, after it
gets deployed, that
we haven't broken
anything in the other crazy
cases that we've seen, right?
So taking the time to build
those in-production tests,
that has been useful
in this other problem.
So we've changed things as a
result. These are some of them.
I'll give you a funny example.
You would think that the
number of customers we have
is not a debatable
or difficult concept,
but actually it
is, it turns out.
Everybody has a different number
for how many customers we have.
And this has solved
that just by normalizing
what we call a customer.
So, for example, in finance,
if someone comes in on April 10
and leaves on April 12,
and we give them a refund,
as we do, then, as far
as GAAP is concerned,
no money happened.
No money changed hands in total.
And so this is a no-op,
and so it's not a customer.
So finance doesn't count that
as a customer for the month.
In support, that's
not how they view it.
In support, someone
came in and called them.
So obviously, it's a customer.
I talked to them.
It must have been a customer.
Who else was I talking to?
So it counts.
And so when support's
thinking, OK, I'm
trying to do capacity planning
and hiring planning, and how
many customers we get a month,
and, therefore, how many people
I need, and blah, blah, blah.
And we have about 250 or
300 people in support.
So this planning is important.
And getting the details
right is important
because it's a lot of folks
that we might need to hire.
They need to count
that as a customer,
or they're not going to get
their hiring plan right.
And similarly, finance
needs to, I guess,
not count them as a customer,
so that we're correct with GAAP.
So the point being,
by forcing ourselves
to see all of this stuff,
even different definitions
of the same concept,
like a customer,
it forced us to go, OK, what
do we really mean by this?
What do we need to mean?
We might need the concept
of a GAAP customer,
or a real customer.
We might need
different words, even.
And with all the
data in one place,
we can produce all
of those numbers.
So everyone can get the data
that they actually need.
But we can actually normalize
what we're talking about.
So if you think it's
bad for a customer,
you can imagine things that are
less simple, how confusing that
was getting.
Anyway, so it's
helped us normalize
how we talk about
things and report
on things, which has
been really nice,
and other things like this.
OK.
Well, I guess
we'll call it then.
Thanks, everybody.
Thanks for your time.
[MUSIC PLAYING]